[Música]
la economía creo que esto es lo más
importante
aquí en pensilvania las situaciones como
la de todas partes con el cob y de hecho
yo perdí mi trabajo hace poco a causa de
esto
[Música]
es bueno culpando la pandemia por la
economía
bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
postales de campaña la cobertura
especial de france 24 en estas
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu
nuestro viaje a los 6 estados clave en
estos comicios hoy nos trae hasta
pensilvania cuna de la constitución de
este país aquí los demócratas se
apoyaron en la clase obrera durante
décadas pero el declive de la industria
manufacturera dio alas al discurso
económico de donald trump en el 2016
muchos votantes que se sentían
abandonados vieron en el actual
presidente a unos sider de la política
que podía devolverles ese apogeo
económico que habían visto en el pasado
pero cuatro años después estos bastiones
republicanos ya no son tan fieles y
donald trump ve como poco a poco cae su
apoyo en el llamado 'cinturón del óxido
vamos a conocer más detalles de esta
zona industrial del país
qué sabemos de pensilvania
ubicado en la costa este entre maryland
de nueva york y ohio pensilvania no es
muy grande en eeuu un poco más de 119
mil kilómetros cuadrados los montes
apalaches lo cruzan sin embargo
pensilvania está densamente poblado más
de 12 millones de habitantes una
población mayoritariamente concentrada
en las grandes ciudades del estado como
filadelfia o pittsburgh pensilvania ha
sido durante mucho tiempo una tierra
industrial la extracción de hierro y
carbón de los apalaches hizo su riqueza
hasta los años 70 hoy el gas de esquisto
le ha dado nueva vida a este sector
aunque la tasa de desempleo es una de
las más altas del país conocido como el
estado clave pensilvania hace honor a su
nombre es un territorio decisivo en cada
elección están en juego 20 votos del
colegio electoral y los resultados
siguen siendo ajustados en cuestión una
división de su población votantes
demócratas cerca de filadelfia y
republicanos cerca del estado de ohio
desde 1992 el estado ha votado por el
candidato demócrata en 2016 trampa había
ganado por un corto margen poco más de
40 mil votos
estamos en el barrio donde creció wider
aquí como ven el activismo político
comienza en las puertas de las casas a
las que hemos llamado para conocer
cuáles son los temas que más preocupan a
los estadounidenses en esta recta final
de la carrera hacia la casa blanca
[Música]
la economía creo que esto es lo más
importante creo que claramente las
políticas de trump tienen más sentido
aquí en pensilvania las situaciones como
la de todas partes con el hobbit y su
gestión de hecho yo perdí mi trabajo
hace poco a causa de esto
cuando se está saliendo de una pandemia
de una situación como la que hemos
tenido en nuestra economía subir por
ejemplo los impuestos y cambiar las
fuentes de energía no tiene ningún
sentido no veo que haya hecho nada por
el trabajador promedio hablan de
reducción de impuestos de recibir más
dinero en el salario lo único que recibí
fue una reducción en mi declaración de
renta tras el declive industrial muchas
ciudades de pensilvania quedaron
devastadas por el desempleo y el éxodo
de la población aquí algunos continúan
luchando por salir adelante es el caso
de los habitantes de youngstown una
pequeña ciudad obrera al noreste del
estado a la que ha viajado un equipo de
france 24
a sus 68 años richard barker ha estado
explorando las zonas industriales
abandonadas de johnstown desde hace 4
décadas este historiador es hoy el
recuerdo de lo que fue una de las joyas
de la industria siderúrgica
estadounidense en saná
estamos en el corazón de lo que una vez
fue la sociedad metalúrgica de cambio
esta compañía comenzó sus actividades
aquí en youngstown en 1854
este lugar albergaba algunos verdaderos
tesoros geológicos la colina detrás de
mí estaba llena de metales y carbón
había minas por toda la montaña y este
lugar se consideraba uno de los filones
más rentables de todo eeuu y entrada de
vinagres y aires states hasta 18.000
trabajadores trabajaron en estos
talleres hoy sólo hay unos pocos
centenares con el apoyo de la
municipalidad patrick quinn intenta
perpetuar el saber hacer de las
herrerías de johnstown creando
herramientas a la antigua
ya
razer beijing para nosotros el desafío
es simplemente preservar la memoria de
la producción metalúrgica de la ciudad
creo que la gran mayoría de la gente
aquí está orgullosa de su herencia pero
no tan orgullosos como para querer usar
estos edificios y máquinas para otra
cosa que no sea la historia no tan
orgullosos como para ver la oportunidad
de crear empleos en este sector hoy en
día beijing las noches
en el siglo 20 las fábricas de johnstown
exportaban vías férreas a todo el mundo
pero lo que antes era una industria
ahora es más bien un trabajo artesanal
así que para sobrevivir los
descendientes de los metalúrgicos de
johnstown tuvieron que adaptarse la
familia frei toft ha estado construyendo
y exportando muebles de pensilvania
durante dos generaciones
vendemos muebles a un precio más bajo
hoy que hace 20 años y la única manera
de hacerlo es a través de la innovación
tecnológica exportamos a arabia saudita
áfrica y europa desde nuestra vieja
ciudad de johnstown con investigación
innovación reducción de costos de
producción son las palabras clave de la
empresa familiar todos nuestros
proyectos los ejecutaremos a través de
ese primer sistema que optimizará todos
los paneles y dirá que este es el mejor
rendimiento que obtendremos del material
reduce el desperdicio y hace que nuestro
taller sea más eficiente
johnston no recuperará a su antiguo
esplendor industrial pero con una tasa
de desempleo igual al promedio nacional
la pequeña ciudad de pensilvania ha
logrado reinventarse a sí misma
[Música]
la economía también es definitivamente
una parte importante creo que donald
trump ha hecho un trabajo bastante
sólido hasta ahora con la economía para
mí personalmente la educación y conozco
muchos otros estudiantes universitarios
para quienes también el acceso a la
educación ya la salud porque eso es algo
de lo que no tenemos que preocuparnos
ahora pero si cuando sean los adultos
y para conocer esta transformación
política que ha vivido pensilvania en
los últimos años hoy nos acompaña james
harris profesora de ciencias políticas
en la universidad de scranton ella ha
sido profesora aquí en los últimos 33
años y también ha sido testigo de esa
evolución política de como los
republicanos poco a poco han ido ganando
terreno aquí en pensilvania algo que
llama la atención porque como es posible
que la clase obrera confíe en un magnate
un rico magnate procedente de wall
street
bueno él no se presenta a sí mismo de
esa manera y le habla a las personas
como si fuera uno de ellos y habla mucho
sobre la clase trabajadora
estadounidense sobre mejorar su
situación y las personas le creen si nos
fijamos en los datos para ver lo que
realmente ha logrado muchas de sus
promesas las ha cumplido aunque yo diría
que las económicas no pero las personas
estaban cansadas de los candidatos del
establecimiento y hillary clinton era
vista así también trump habló de una
manera distinta como suelen hacerlo los
políticos y eso parece haber resonado
con las personas y creo que podríamos
culpar a los demócratas de haber perdido
el apoyo de los votantes aquí en
pensilvania
creo que a lo largo del país el partido
demócrata no ha sido consciente del
núcleo de votantes que tiene entonces sí
a lo largo del país las personas se han
ido pasando al otro lado claramente aquí
en el condado de la cca van a hillary si
ganó la vez pasada pero estuvo muy cerca
en comparación con cómo le había ido a
obama en el condado de luzerne al sur de
nosotros trump si gano
en parte es culpa del partido demócrata
y ellos lo reconocen y están tratando de
hacer algunos cambios y en parte fue a
causa de la singularidad de trump contra
hillary clinton
hace cuatro años muchos votantes de esta
zona confiaron en donald trump porque
veían en él un hombre de negocios que
podría recuperar esa época de bonanza
cuatro años después continúa siendo así
continúan confiando en él
su núcleo de votantes y
creo que la vez pasada reunió personas
menos educadas votantes blancos en
educación universitaria y ellos todavía
le creen no estoy muy segura porque
viendo el estado de la economía
[Música]
ciertamente la pandemia ha cambiado
algunas cosas y trump es muy bueno
culpando a la pandemia por la economía
pero realmente no estaba tan bien antes
de la pandemia como él lo sugiere tiene
un grupo central de votantes y les sigue
hablando en la manera que a ellos les
gusta porque creen que trump dice las
cosas como son no es un político típico
[Música]
es algo que se respira en esta región es
un sentimiento de nostalgia de aquellos
años dorados en los que la economía
estaba mucho mejor cuáles son las
expectativas de futuro creo que aquí en
pensilvania la población está cambiando
nos estamos volviendo una población más
diversa históricamente pensilvania y
scranton específicamente ha sido muy
diverso en términos de etnicidad blanca
siempre hemos sido una especie de crisol
las personas han llegado a la ciudad y
ahora tenemos más diversidad en términos
de personas afroamericanas también
la comunidad está cambiando también hay
más personas mudándose reubicándose aquí
desde las áreas metropolitanas como
filadelfia o nueva york porque el costo
de vida es mucho más bajo la comunidad
realmente está cambiando todavía tenemos
miembros de hace mucho tiempo si no se
nace en scranton nunca se es scranton ya
no pero si se nace aquí como yo bailé
uno siempre será scranton ya no la
comunidad misma está tratando de
revitalizar se tenemos un nuevo alcalde
una mujer alcaldesa por primera vez en
la ciudad de scranton y estamos
desarrollando una verdadera esperanza la
ciudad pasó de 140 mil en su apogeo en
términos de población a unos 70 mil hubo
deterioro urbano y todas esas cosas que
ocurrieron pero realmente ha habido un
impulso reciente por involucrar más a
los ciudadanos y por hacer cambios
reales y tratar de hacer cambios en la
economía creo que hay una esperanza que
habíamos perdido
profesora jane harris muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros en este episodio
muchas gracias por invitarme
[Música]
el tren de vaivén para recuperar la
confianza de la clase obrera en este
estado avanza a pocas horas de que se
celebre la gran noche electoral ambos
candidatos se han peleado hasta el
último momento por pensilvania que se ha
convertido en la piedra angular de estos
comicios quién se quedará con ella es
algo que descubriremos muy pronto y este
es ya nuestro último episodio de
postales de campaña un programa que nos
ha permitido tomarle el pulso real al
país en los días previos a las
elecciones presidenciales gracias
también al equipo que hay detrás de las
cámaras que ustedes no ven pero nos ha
ayudado a contarles esta realidad
quédense con nosotros porque en otras 24
estaremos contándole la última hora de
estos históricos comicios a través de
nuestros noticieros y programas
especiales y en nuestras redes sociales
así como en la página web france24
puntocom
[Música]